y tenemos esta división 9.319 entre 66
vamos a reescribir lo para que sea mucho
más sencillo y lo podamos trabajar 9.319
lo dividiremos entre 66 y estas
divisiones con dos dígitos se vuelven un
poquito como un arte un poco más de
estar aproximando y un poco más de estar
midiendo posibilidades dentro de los
números para saber que no nos hemos
pasado ya les explicaré más adelante
vamos a empezar con cuántas veces cabe
el 66 en el 9
bueno pues de hecho no cabe ninguna así
es que podemos considerar entonces la
siguiente cifra cuantas veces que habrá
ahora 66 en 93 esto sí tiene sentido y
de hecho podemos decir que 66 cabe una
vez
en el 93 si hacemos la multiplicación
166 será igual a 66 y podremos hacer la
resta este 13 es menor que este 6 por lo
que cambiaremos este 9 a un 8 le
quitaremos una decena
y la prestaremos de este lado en vez de
tres
ahora será 13 y ahora si tenemos 13 6 y
8 menos 6 ambos números de arriba son
mayores que los de abajo 13 menos 6 es
igual a 7
8 - 6 es igual a 2 y vamos bien como lo
sé porque este 27 este residuo es más
pequeño que el 66 entre el que estamos
dividiendo el número original
así es que podemos bajar el siguiente
dígito de nuestro número tendremos ahora
271 entre 66 a mí lo que me gusta pensar
y aquí es donde empieza el arte a mí lo
que me gusta pensar es redondear este 66
hacia las escenas más próxima en este
caso está más cerca del 70 que del 60
y este 271 cuando está más cercano al
así es que puedo hacer una aproximación
donde me pregunto cuántas veces cabe el
7 en 27 si yo multiplico por 37 por 3 es
igual a 21 7 por 4 es igual a 28 se
pasaría 7 por 5 es igual a 35 se pasa
pensemos entonces en 3
si yo hago la división considerando un 3
aquí tendré 3 por 3 18
llevo 13 x 6 18 y una que llevo 19 vamos
a hacer la resta ahora de 271 menos 198
vamos a volver a hacer nuestras
reorganizaciones dado que el 1 es más
pequeño que el 8 y el 7 es más pequeño
que el 9 vamos a pedirle prestado a este
a esta centena
y la convertiremos en una sola centena
prestándole así
otra centena para acá este 7 de decenas
era 17 decenas 17 9 sin embargo aquí
todavía nos va a faltar este 17 lo
convertiremos en 16 y este 1 se
convertirá en 11 porque le hemos
prestado una decena de la posición que
está al lado izquierdo
ahora tenemos 11 menos 8 16 menos 7 y 1
menos 111 menos 8 es igual a 3
dieciséis menos nueve es igual a 71
menos 1 es igual a cero este 3 no nos
funciona porque porque el número que nos
está dando como residuo es más grande
que esté 66 entre el cual estamos
dividiendo el número original eso no
significa que todavía esté 66 cabe una
vez en este 73 están de acuerdo vamos
entonces a deshacer lo que habíamos
hecho
y vamos a poner en vez de tres
4 porque el residuo nos dio noticias de
que cabe todavía una vez más 4 por 6 24
llevamos 24 por 6 24 más 2 que llevamos
25 26 ahora si esto se ve mucho más
cercano
hacemos la recta y a 271 264 ya lo
podemos hacer simplemente con la cabeza
y se da 7 lo hacemos de memoria si aún
no lo sabemos de memoria vamos a hacer
nuestra respectiva reagrupación
tenemos este uno es más pequeño que este
4 este 7 es más grande así es que es que
le pediremos prestado a este 7 una de
las decenas se convertirá en 6 y este 1
se convertirá en 11 ya que le hemos
trasladado una de las decenas que hemos
pedido prestadas 11 menos 4 es igual a 7
66 igual a 0 22 igual a cero perfecto y
con esto nos damos cuenta ahora que el 7
es menor que el 66 por lo que el 4 fue
una excelente opción bajamos el
siguiente dígito que es el 9
79 cuántas veces cabe el número 66 en el
número 79 pues nos cabe una sola vez
166 66 si hacemos la resta tendremos 9 6
3 7 6 11 13 de esta manera nuestra
respuesta indicará qué 9.319 entre 66
será igual a 141 estoy usando los mismos
colores
de acuerdo a la operación que hemos
hecho sin embargo es importante que aquí
aclaremos que va a haber un recibo
de 13 esta será nuestra respuesta
correcta
nos vemos en otro vídeo